hey there welcome back to Simply learn
today we are diving into the world of
cyber security to explore two
fundamental concepts hashing and
encryption have you ever wondered how
your passwords are stored securely or
how data is kept confidential during
transmission well today's video is for
you we will be comparing hashing and
encryption breaking down the differences
and discussing their respective use
cases but before we dive in if you are
new here don't forget to subscribe and
hit the Bell icon to stay updated and
just a quick info for you if you want to
upscale yourself master cyber security
skills and learn your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learns cohort of various cyber
Security Programs simply learn offers
various certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
MIT I khur EC Council and many mo
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work expertise in skills
like Advanced hacking Concepts Network
packet analysis ethical hacking network
security and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire product and security
companies and acadm misss from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a cyber security role
as a fresher or move on to a higher
paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin command and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of
interest and now moving to our topic and
first we'll start with what is
hashing so first up let's talk about
hashing and hashing is a process that
takes input data and produces a fix size
string of characters which is typically
a hash value this process is one way
meaning you can't reverse it to obtain
the original data the key here is the
same input will always produce the same
hash but even a small change in the
input will result in a completely
different hash so this is hashing and
now we'll see the use cases for hashing
hashing is commonly used for password
storage when you create an account on a
website your password isn't stored in
plain text instead it's hashed adding a
layer of security this way even if a
database is compromised
hackers won't have direct access to your
passwords hashing is also used to check
data Integrity for example file check
sumps use hashing to verify that a file
hasn't been corrupted so these are the
use cases for hashing now moving
on hashing as a general practice adheres
to certain principles that Define its
characteristics number one is
deterministic output a consistent input
should always yield a predictable output
ensuring reliability in hash generation
next is irreversibility once hashed it
should be computationally infeasible to
reverse the process and retrieve the
original input enhancing security and
then comes uniqueness distinct inputs
must result in distinct hash values
preventing collisions with different
inputs produce the same hash and then
comes sensitivity to input changes even
a minor modification in the input should
lead to a subst potential change in the
hash maintaining the Integrity of the
hashing process and now a hash algorithm
serving as the mechanism for hashing
functions to transform data of varing
sizes into fixed size data it yields
hash values hash cods or hash sums as
outcome and various hashing algorithms
have been utilized in Computing with
some becoming obsolute over time some
examples are md4 that is created by Ron
dve West in 1990 md4 has a 128bit length
but faces security criticisms including
concerns tased by its own Creator and
then comes sh algorithm that is
developed by the National Security
Agency sh has a 160 bit length due to
security vulnerabilities organizations
now prefer to robust sh2 that is 256bit
algorithm for cryptographic
purposes and then comes RP EMD that is
designed by H dotin with a 160 bit
length repm was created within the
framework of the EU project ripe and
then comes wpo
algorithm that is convinced by Vincent
ran and Paul Barto and this
202056 bit algorithm produces a 512 bit
message digest and then we have tiger
algorithm that is recognized for its
speed and efficiency tiger hashes or 132
million bits per second surpassing other
discussed algorithm it stands out for
its unrestricted usage devoid of any
patents so this was about hashing and
now we'll move to
encryption so unlike hashing encryption
is a two-way process it uses algorithms
to transform data into a format that is
unreadable without the appropriate
decryption key the main goal of
encryption is to protect the
confidentiality of data ensuring that
unauthorized parties can't access or
understand
it and now we'll see the use cases of
encryption encryption is used in various
scenarios when you send sensitive
information over the Internet like
credit card details or personal messages
encryption ensures that even if
intercepted the data is meaningless
without the proper decryption key it's
also widely used in securing
Communications such as https for secure
browsing additionally encrypt storage
protects data on your devices from
unauthorized access and there are a
number of encryption systems where an
asymmetric encryption is also known as
public key encryption symmetric
encryption and hybrid encryption are the
most common so symmetric encryption it
uses the same secret key to encrypt and
decrypt the message the secret key can
be of word a number or a string of
random letters both the sender and the
receiver should have the key it is the
oldest technique of encryption and then
comes asymmetric encryption it deploys
two keys a public key known by everyone
and a private key known only by the
receiver the public key is used to
encrypt the message and a private key is
used to decrypt it a symmetric
encryption is little slower than
symmetric encryption and consumes more
processing power when encrypting data
and then comes hybrid encryption it is a
process of encryption that blends both
symmetric and and a symmetric encryption
it takes advantage of the strengths of
the two encryptions and minimizes their
weaknesses and now we'll see the purpose
of encryption the main idea of
encryption is to protect data from an
unauthorized person who wants to read or
get information from a message that was
not intended for them encryption
enhances security when sending messages
through the internet or through any
given Network the following are the key
elements of security that encryption has
to
enhance number one is
confidentiality encrypted message cannot
be read or Changed by another person
encrypt it transforms data in such a way
that only specific individuals can
transform the message granular Access
Control users are limited to what they
can see and do it makes auditing for
accountability easy in the case of
message leaked it is easy to trace who
did that and when the security Bridges
can be sorted out effectively
then authentication the origin of the
message received can be traced thus
facilitating authentication and some of
the most popular encryption algorithms
are AES and pgp AES is a symmetric
encryption algorithm while pgp is an
example of an asymmetric encryption
algorithm used today and now coming to
difference between encryption and
hashing encryption and quotes data to
maintain confidentiality and security
requiring a private key for reversible
decryption and hashing ensures content
Integrity by detecting modifications and
altering the hash output encryption
involves a two-way process encryption
and decryption while hashing is a
one-way process producing an
irreversible unique digest both hashing
and encryption plays vital roles in
handling data messages and information
in Computing systems they transform data
into different formats but encryption is
reversible whereas hashing is is note
and now talking about the length output
so encryption has variable length and
hashing has fixed length and about the
types so encryption has a symmetric
symmetric and hybrid types and hashing
as hashing
types and now talking about the common
algorithms so encryption has AES rc4
Dees RSA ecdsa and hashing as sh1 sh2
md5 crc32 and bput
so this was about the difference between
encryption and hashing and now
continuous advancements are crucial to
adapt to evolving attack strategies
emphasizing the need for upto-date
hashing and encryption methods and
staying current with the latest
techniques is imperative to enhance
Security in modern Computing systems and
adopting contemporary methods ensures
resilience against everchanging threats
and maintains robust data prot action so
this was all for this tutorial hope you
guys found it informative and helpful if
you like this session then like share
and subscribe and if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here